e aí
e quantas pessoas perguntam que eu faço
eu adoro dizer que eu sou um construtor
de pontos
e na verdade usa a fotografia para
construir ponte que conecta em pessoas
que conecta em mundos lugares diferentes
nos últimos dez doze anos eu venho
desenvolvendo o projeto na área de saúde
no brasil e várias partes no mundo muito
que eu tentar entender todo esse
universo do cuidar como ele funciona a
organização mundial de saúde diz que a
cada um dólar que a gente investe em
educação e promoção de saúde a gente
economiza cinco dólares no curativista a
questão aqui poucos projetos eu vi ao
longo de dez anos região do mundo de
prevenção de saúde ia perguntar porque é
tão mais humano é tão mais legal é mais
barato mas não acontece acontece muito
pouco
o vestido de vagas lugares como o haiti
depois do terremoto
e depois eu fui para o japão
e depois do tsunami e entre haiti e
japão na verdade eu fui muito para
tentar entender esse universo do cuidar
no lugar caótico no lugar onde teve uma
crise uma tragédia muito grande
e depois eu fui para vários lugares como
na áfrica como esse outro eles voltam
pequeno país na áfrica do sul depois eu
estive em uganda
o e outros países mais como ruanda
burundi tudo tentando entender essa
questão da humanização na verdade quando
volto de viagem as pessoas me perguntam
como é que eu consigo fazer esse tipo de
viagem
e essa não fica acabado triste deprimido
doente claro gente claro que tem dias em
campo que é muito difícil que eu sofro
que é muito dolorido mas o fundo quando
eu volto de viagem eu volto me sentindo
parte de algo muito maior do que eu
mesmo
o começo a perceber que a gente tem
muito medo muito medo de se envolver
para dor do outro a gente se afasta para
se proteger mas quando a gente faz isso
eu acho que a gente pega uma solidão
dentro da gente conseguir dar o meio sem
sentido e aí eu percebi uma das coisas
mais legais no meu trabalho que me deu
sentido
e no meu quarto de foto eu percebi que
quando a gente reconhecer a dor do outro
e nós mesmos nós seremos curados plantas
da solidão do tédio cuidados aquela
tristeza profunda que bate nosso coração
e a gente não sabe nem porque é
e tu disse que a gente falou está muito
relacionado
e com a filosofia antiga chamada ubuntu
que significa eu sou porque nós somos eu
sou porque nós somos sem feliz quando
nós formos felizes ser realizado quando
nós fomos realizados isso é demais meu
oi e aí eu trouxe mais histórias para
dividir com vocês
e essa foto foi feita not bite depois do
terremoto eu cheguei no haiti em porto
príncipe foi muito difícil chegar lá
e quando eu chegar eu trabalhei com
algumas organizações como a cruz
vermelha a qual o no que os médicos sem
fronteira é com vários acampamentos na
verdade e aí eu conheci essa menina
e ela foi retirada dos escombros depois
de alguns dias tentaram salvar a perna
dela não conseguiram
é mas eu gostaria muito que vocês
olhassem para esta imagem de uma maneira
diferente
e olha o carinho o acolhimento que ela
está recebendo isso é muito poderoso e
aí me ver uma frase incrível de uma
médica chamada de iniciei que diz que o
sofrimento ele só intolerável quando
ninguém cuida
é mas pra gente cuidar a gente precisa
primeiro o que olhar para o outro e
quando a gente olha pro outro a gente
começa a sentir parte de algo muito
maior do que a gente mesmo
e aí
e a gente começa a sentir parte na
verdade do nosso
oi e aí sobre nós eu trouxe outra
história super rebel xsi
eu estive no amazonas trabalha com
várias etnias indígenas mas esse povo é
o povo yanomami
é a coisa do nós preguiça é tão forte
o que existiu eu eles não tem nome
próprio todos têm o mesmo nome da maloca
que eles vivem
quem fez isso nossa
e isso é tão forte lá por exemplo essa
foto com a mãe com a criança não
necessariamente esta criança
e foi parida dessa mulher todas as
mulheres são mães todas as crianças são
filhas são genial né gente às vezes eu
da aldeia e você vê uma mãe amamentando
uma criança que não foi agora te falei
eu inclusive eu acho que isso aqui na
nossa sociedade é ser fantástico você já
pensavam as mulheres uma sexta-feira
louca pegar levar uma lida para tomar
cerveja comer uma pizza e tem alguém
cuidando do seu filho massa né de
repente né aí outro dia você está super
animada fala hoje não hoje eu vou cuidar
de 3
é bom demais né
e essa foto ela foi feita na áfrica do
sul
e na verdade na áfrica tem um índice de
hz muito alto e ela acontece tem uma
situação que é o seguinte você tem de um
lado pais que perderam seus filhos por
causa do hiv e de outro lado você tem
crianças que perderam seus pais por
causa do hiv
o que é que você quer saber algo que no
coração dos dois tinham vazio tinha um
espaço para ser preenchido e esse criar
um programa de adoção entre essas
pessoas que foram sucesso essa mulher
adotou todas essas crianças
e depois eu teve uganda
e o gato trabalha no hosp para quem sabe
um hotfix é o tipo de hospital um pouco
mais simples isso que cuida das pessoas
quando elas não tem mais cura quando
elas têm dias semanas meses de vida e o
cuidar dele é diferente o cuidado é para
você evitar dor que aquela fique bem até
o final da vida dela mas esse corte
dizer que eles vão alguém o daqui que
eles fazem eles levam os pacientes para
dentro de casa para que isso morro
dentro de casa faça os últimos dias com
a sua família são demais
olá tudo disse para vocês que eu acho
que a gente tem medo do sofrimento e da
dor dos outros com certeza a gente tem
medo da morte eu tenho medo da morte
é mas a foto aqui a chance que eu tive
de entrar em contato com a mente estão
difíceis na vida das pessoas
e me proporcionou não pela morte do meu
lado o sofrimento do meu lado muito pelo
contrário hoje eu sinto que eu consigo
ver a vida de uma maneira diferente eu
sinto mais vida uma presença vou aqui
agora eu acho que é isso que falta eu
acho que a gente se aproximar e olhar a
gente aprende com isso
e de fato a fotografia é uma ferramenta
incrível para construir pontes
a régua é muito poderosa para você
construir vínculo com as pessoas empatia
com as pessoas porque percebeu o mundo
em que se vive é o primeiro passo pela
modificado
e aí na verdade já percebi outra coisa a
gente não precisa
oi e para uganda plate para ruanda pra
me conectar com alguém eu posso fazer
isso aqui um amigo com conhecido
e com desconhecido às vezes uma pequena
atitude faz toda a diferença na vida de
alguém e quando eu faço isso eu me sinto
muito mais humano
e na verdade gente eu sou porque nós
somos obrigado
e aí